hello ladies and gentlemen I have a
friend here
this is Greg me yep what's your name sir
I'm Jordan Ross Jordan Ross
we go way back many years ago I liked
all it's my over years well years I
think so yeah we haven't seen each other
like a decade yeah
yeah but we were in an acting boot camp
together huh young performers studio yes
good times
hyojung they hope your wanna Jean go
Jean hope you're watching our success
yeah on the Internet Jordan has a
YouTube channel Sydenham mad dicks yeah
there's a text here but for you guys to
understand actually down there but yeah
or whatever here you control the video
we're gonna talk about the dunker
trailer and christopher nolan's new
movie yeah I haven't read anything about
this film so far I know you guys wanted
me to do a reaction to it I saw the
trailer for the first time already
before Suicide Squad so I can't do a
reaction to it because that would be a
lie yeah would it be genuine it wouldn't
be genuine like most reactors out there
they're liars yeah I want you guys to
know that the biggest reactors Tyrone
Magnus all eight hundred forty thousand
of his subs all from redoing reactions
over that Star Wars one that went viral
mmm-hmm he had filmed that like 18 times
before he actually posted one you should
be ashamed she'd be ashamed I want you
to tell me the brief explanation of what
you were kind of talking about so I
guess I it's I read that it's based on a
true story about a big evacuation during
World War two but it was in the middle
of this giant battle and what I know
about the movie is that it picks up like
right in the middle of this giant battle
an evacuation it doesn't ease into it at
all okay like in savings I say Iraq with
their gun day seemed so apparently yeah
picks it up up right in the middle of it
you know stars Mark Rylance he's in it
I think Killian Murphy's in it the one
direction got Harry Styles I've never
seen him act so maybe if Christopher
Nolan is putting him in his movie I'm
assuming that he's good in it when I got
a say from the pros from what I've seen
from the trailer because no one's been
doing like a lot of fiction yeah sci-fi
we got into this kind reminds you of the
days you know not necessarily memento
but like more like insomnia yeah where
it was just about people in a situation
yeah you know and then this like from
the dramatic shots we're getting it's
like it doesn't look like it's going all
Nolan s
in terms of like crazy imagination huh
it looks like it's about these
characters being affected by this battle
situation exactly yeah she's I want to
see no one explore that again because he
has been he delivers these great
Hollywood films it's been a while since
we got like an insomnia kind of film
from Nolan yeah it's kind of a departure
from what he's done recently which I
like and we haven't seen him do a big
war epic either oh yeah that's a big
deal drama yes I'm excited about that
it'll be really cool to to see how he
how he approaches it what I love though
from this trailer it's done like every
Nolan trailer even though the text is
from every exact everything I saw this
movie with my friend Johnny has no job
at that last moment where everyone is
like some people started noticing
something yeah there's a whole wave
happen you're like a plane or a VM
falling rocks yeah trailer ends right
away I was like there you go yo land
just sold that whole movie because
everyone wants to know what the [ __ ]
everyone was like yeah same kind of
texts it flashes a reminder of the
film's he's done before he releases
teasers for his movies so far in advance
like it doesn't come out for another
year usually they'll release trailers
you know like six months before the
movie or whatever interstellar he
released the first teaser for that like
over a year but remember that it makes
everyone just like I want to see more
but you have to wait so long to see it I
wonder if the mysterious vibe will still
be present in like the next trailer
because he does deal a lot with his
films having a level of mystery and
intrigue yeah and the trailer is being
like I don't know exactly what the [ __ ]
this movie's about but this like we got
a true story outline and people are
saying it but you know he still does the
nolan stuff where he shot a lot of this
with imax yeah have you seen any Nolan's
films and IMAX yes I think I'm almost
out like all the Batman movies and
interstellar in Inception
I saw the Dark Knight and as the first
movie ever like first that you guys only
would film yeah to have personally
oversaw yeah yeah it was the first movie
that ever come out that featured IMAX
cameras that's right because there's
like IMAX movies but then yeah the first
film to have like IMAX cameras for
certain scenes uh-huh and I was just
blown away
to this day it is the best use of IMAX
cameras I've seen and I heard they
destroyed one I do not know maybe I
think it was the Joker car chasing I
think they destroyed one of the IMAX
cameras and it's like half a million
dollar because they were much bigger
than yeah they were they're dealing with
each amateur
yeah X camera yeah I mean it's gonna be
cool to see and I next one like this I
wonder if I mean Nolan doesn't do RA
flicks really but in saw me it was rated
R momentos radar I wonder if this is
gonna be radar it's the true story of
battles and stuff with a war movie I
almost have to make it you know live up
to its potential to make it truthful
since it is a true story it almost has
to be rated R to show the horrors yeah
absolutely
you know dangers of war and you know how
scary it is yeah this is a movie you
can't have fast with this rating no and
uh it looks like it's a big-budget like
Warner Bros cuz Warner Brothers is at
the point where like whatever you want
Nolan yeah whatever you want could make
ask to make anything and they would be
yeah okay here's you know twenty million
dollars go to it so it's like more for
Warner Brothers too because I'm sure
this is gonna be an expensive asset
films yeah I fact alone that he's using
the IMAX cameras for war movie alone is
like this is probably an expensive film
and our rating this could be a big step
especially for a backrub big studio
movies example clip all out with an
r-rating yeah because I don't know why
but Studios have been like trepidatious
about already and they feel like it you
know kind of uh limits their audience a
little bit more they feel like but it's
like we were saying we saw rated our
movies in the aggregate Saving Private
Ryan was my favorite movie when it came
out when I was seven especially with a
war movie I feel like even if has a lot
of gore for kids to see that it's kind
of important because it's like it shows
what you know real things that actually
happen and you know they can get an idea
for things that our ancestors and stuff
had to actually deal with I mean ratings
like like I don't think you should just
focus on the rating alone it's like it
the context plus rating yeah and for the
context of this rating is very important
yeah so I hope this is an r-rated film
me too and like especially when you're
teasing a sequence it looks like it
could be an epic showdown yeah I'm
hoping that spill would like blood
because I really wonder what no one can
differently with this film a week ago I
saw the shutter for hacksaw Ridge which
was no gift since war movie yeah and it
looks like a totally different kind of
vibe of a war film yeah that will
probably have an all right oh not be as
gruesome I feel like with this though
you might need some of that gore in
there more than a fury Saving Private
Ryan kind of vibe for sure yeah I really
hope they go that direction too that'll
be cool to see most of his movies have
been you know contemporary they've been
like modern-day and prestige is one that
it was like a period or ago yeah so I'm
excited to see him go back into that
area a little bit again because I look I
think that's one of the more underrated
Christopher Nolan movies something is
great you know I'm interested to see him
tackle something that takes place you
know in in history you know something
that that's a little different from
modern day too because a lot of his
films work off mystery and intrigue and
this is true story yeah so I feel like
already with true story and knowing
facts yeah like and it sounds like he's
honoring the truth and making it a
historical fiction piece it takes away
some of that Nolan element of
mysteriousness to it
but I still feel like I mean just the
trailer this is a lot of like the
trailer yeah me too I would say marketed
exactly did it show like really any no
no completely like I'm so so and I watch
this yeah yeah they could just show up
and just say Christopher Nolan Dunkirk
yeah or just Christopher Nolan at that
point when Nolan yeah yeah JJ Abrams is
sort of losing that touch now uh-huh
we're like okay we get it you do
mysterious thing let's see you produce
every movie with Christopher Nolan he
only does a movie every like you know
three or four years a career so well the
thing is that JJ and was produces a lot
in between directing yeah usually his
films are marketed well but then when
they're released you're like it's not as
much seriously rewarding as I thought
yeah it's actually great like I liked it
but yeah but it wasn't like this big
mysterious yet read that we were hoping
for exactly give and send a force
awakens yep
great Star Wars film but rather simple
simpler than we expect yeah you know but
Nolan I love that people still debate
his phone yeah me too it's never gonna
end
it's like Hitchcock like you know he's
he's kind of like a modern day he does
have there's different movies but it's
like the same kind of thing where it's
like people will be talking about his
movies forever it's like a massive
Hitchcock yeah yeah and I love that he
takes his time a lot of directors once
they start making it big studios will
come to them and be like hey we want you
to make this movie and they're like okay
and they just do whatever they just
cranked movies out yeah like no one
takes his time he picks things that he
wants to do things that he's super
passionate about and he makes sure that
it's done right absolutely and I Ayers
like a very professional director Oh way
shows up on set wearing his house bunola
outfit yeah I heard he doesn't have a
cell phone or an email address Wow his
work just done through his assistant in
his landline typewriter all right well
yeah sorry we can't provide the reaction
hotel you like or talk if you're new to
this channel it is called the real
rejects we have subscription services
subscribe you pay $4.99 a month and you
get unlimited access to all the videos
on this free youtube channel nice
Sydenham medics yes not to be confused
with cinema nothing all right yeah not
confusing I just go there young Jordan
has a lot of videos on there that I saw
like a few before watching that and I
was really happy he's here because I'm
like yes I have another big movie buff
and I want to get like I want more big
movie buffs to come on this channel and
yeah if you're if you're a movie buff
you'll definitely love a lot of his
topic videos on there yes
so yeah and shout out to Jordans child
yeah hi Ileana hi Aliannah I'll talk to
you in 18 years yeah I can't wait she's
almost 1 so she's almost old enough for
Saving Private Ryan 17 more barrels yeah
yeah the law changes